important to remember that the the
mission of the border patrol is not to
process Asylum Seekers while we're busy
doing this the cartels are taking full
advantage of it somewhere else along the
border to bring in who knows what and
who knows who these are the types of
things like fenel like other Harden
narcotics Harden criminals that do
represent a danger to our community so
as long as we're stuck having to deal
with a migrant influx we cannot be out
on patrol so there was The Man In Charge
border patrol who knows who right
Dawning task for Border Patrol it's only
getting more difficult migrant
encounters went past a million already
this fiscal year fiscal year starts in
the 1 of October folks the fastest that
number has ever been reached Victor Aila
retired ice HSI agent who tragically
knows the danger in securing our border
he's also running for congress in Texas
sir thank you for your time today uh and
good morning that there was a story
yesterday that the president might
consider executive action not now not
today but maybe in the months to come
what do you think he should do or could
do to help out well hopefully the
executive action is to undo his own
executive actions that he did uh three
years ago undoing the uh the Trump's
Administration policies that we know we
were working uh that were working at the
border uh two two of the main ones Bill
remain in Mexico and and catch and
release uh anyone that has worked in
this capacity including myself would
know that these policies were actually
working because it held uh Mexico uh in
check and and and part of the solution
included them and other countries as
well uh this is what we need to go back
to and you know mentioning the numbers
uh 1 million let's not forget about the
these are the ones that we count it
let's not forget about the the the
numbers that are coming here that are
not being detected the known Goda ways
and the unknown God ways and so
according to my calculations uh for the
last three years we're probably past the
15 million Mark of Jo Jo I don't know
where it ends let me get to that in a
moment here Chief Owens told Martha
yesterday during that interview uh
fiscal year 2024 they've app handed 160
undocumented subjects with gang
affiliations uh gangs that are involved
with murder and extortion and narcotics
what do they do when they get away
inside of our country let me tell you a
lot of people don't understand this a
lot of times these individuals these
gang members cartel members actually end
up in the communities back to their own
communities in the US with other
undocumented people and they are also
sometimes the victims at the hands of
these illicit groups and so uh that's
one of the things that I that I fight
for is the victims in this country we're
as you guys report all the time we have
a huge crime surge around the country
now you're adding crime from people from
150 different countries uh in these um
small towns it's not just New York it's
small towns and counties across our
country that are being highly affected
in their criminal justice systems but
they don't have additional police
officers they don't have additional
resources but what suffers is Public
Safety yeah uh fair point one more point
I want to ask you about border crossings
Donald Trump and he was President versus
Joe Biden here's what we got the numbers
from 2018 to 2020 uh just shy of 2.5
million previously under Biden you
you're coming up on 8 million the the
year is Young you have to add the rest
of 2024 onto that number screen right
where are we come November with this
story Victor uh listen someone that
that's on the border all the time and
this is why I'm running for this
important uh position in District 23
because uh I know what's happening we
all know what's happening but for some
reason we can't get that point across to
the Senate and the and the house and
Congress and uh there's this breakdown
of information my l i tell me all the
time what the problem is especially with
the cartels and the imminent threat that
we face and and the bigger picture bill
here of the National Security with China
Iran and all the other issues uh
surrounding our country that you use
Mexico as a springboard to get into our
country um we need to somehow put this
point across and go and back and and be
the voice of the people CU that's what
they're telling me down in District 23
they want representation you wonder if
immigration is a bigger story than
abortion on the ballot is coming
November we shall see Victor thank you
for your time today we'll watch your
campaign see whether or not you succeed
Victor AA thank you for coming on I'm
Steve duy I'm Brian kilme and I'm Angley
aart and click here to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page to catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis